are you ready to make some money you bet
your bottom dollar we are Sims and left
go getting ready to bet week four
ventric is in the house and I could feel
it in my bones more why'd you have to
come in so hard let it breathe the
listeners wanted to BRE want that bring
mouth shut oh you say so this is what
this is what people need to realize is
that Sims doesn't get good sleep you
have a problem telling people they have
problems maybe you should evaluate your
own life instead of constantly
criticizing others but yeah maybe that's
the reason you took this job is you're
like being inherently negative Jared
Goff what he thinks we've got a social
media war unfolding between Chad
Ochocinco and Ray Lewis and all you guys
want to talk about is Chris's personal
life well we were take I was being the
Chad Ochocinco - Sims is Ray Lewis on
the show if you guys haven't seen it on
YouTube Sims left go the show Oh Cho
Cinco aka Chad Johnson aka 85 told a
story with tio we were at blind barber
in LA we were doing a segment about how
he almost beat the crap outta Ray Lewis
we're ray and a safety kind of
sandwiched him and then after the game
he tried to go to the locker room ran
out without a shirt into the parking lot
and rage drove away and he knew Ray was
scared well ray posted the video of the
hit and then then put on an Instagram
that I would knock you out and all that
stuff and it seems like it's all good
natured fun they're friends yeah it all
started on the sims and left go show a
good few trendsetters I love it did you
did you make it response yet what was
the response that we finally went with I
said I asked ray what round would you
not come out right because I wanted to
see if a response will Wheaton's okay
maybe it'd have a little announcement
I've seen a lot of people in social
excited about the shirts $22.00 we don't
see a dime if you put in fantasy the
code when you're buying the shirt it's
three dollars shipping anywhere in the
world
the Loyalists dot-com /sl FL 2018 promo
code fantasy that is the Loyalists com
/sl FL 2018
make sure you find your fantasy
conference name rock it around wear the
shirt posted I'm gonna get the golden
spleen it's our conference the gold and
Sims is going to Notre Dame this weekend
I am so if you want to take pictures of
him while he's on TV and then put words
in his mouth or make a meme make sure to
send us on Twitter or Instagram and we
will retweet it out there pretty big
game hopefully you'll get some followers
too
who is Notre Dame playing this we know
thank you for being such a good friend
first thank you 13 I'm a friend of you I
am NOT a friend of Notre Dame oh I could
care less top 10 matchup top 10 now I
care more that you say something good at
halftime or whenever you go on pregame
thank you then the game no it's it's
Notre Dame Stanford what rank is
Stanford Stanford 7 and he just beat
Oregon they did write which I was
actually shocked to see them come back
over and above Notre Dame especially a
Notre Dame playing so well so Stanford a
7 no name is Notre Dame is 8 you know of
course they're starting a new
quarterback in book took Brandon Wimbush
his job last week I agree I do agree I
think it you saw limitations and Wimbush
his ability to throw yeah winbush he
like he's a great kid great kid he's an
awesome athlete he's really the best
running back on their team I think
they're gonna get them on the field and
some capacity I would Lamar Jackson
something like that yes definitely then
that's all you thinks gonna win I I
don't know if I'm allowed to give those
kind of things at this point really are
you withholding III think the biggest
came for them all year or they have
another big match no I mean Florida
State's fizzle the way they do have
Virginia Tech in Virginia Tech defeated
Syracuse at Yankee Stadium that'll be
good there yeah that's Syracuse is 25
point underdogs to Clemson this weekend
and the best part is is now I get to be
like my Syracuse Orange having found of
all year that'll be cool to see to be
there but I think Notre Dame move on
this will bug you I do
I think Notre Dame's Buena High on them
all you yeah I'm gonna
flip that and put it out Kristen's
official notre-dame production all right
fend requite you fill us in with how we
did boy is another ugly week in week 3
so here's how it went any times a week
do we have to go over this we didn't go
over it you were the one that asked for
it on Monday
was I yeah because you were like when
you lose a lot we talked about all right
so here's what happened so week three
Sims you lost 560 bleacher bucks left go
you lost 400 bleacher bucks
yeah yep what do you mean Oh cuz I told
you to bet big that's what you get I
went big on one today all right so
here's what we got bank accounts for the
season overall Sims you are at minus 940
bleacher bucks right left go you were at
minus 790 who sounds like I'm winning
you are winning overall record Sims you
are 22 and 25 left go you are 21 and 26
sounds like I'm winning I know that
neither of you cares about the records
we are moving on to the individual I
don't even like I don't even want to bet
on some of these games I'd rather not
even bet and be held responsible for
some of these coin flip a few segments
guaranteed to lose Sims last week you
went two and three the bills the
Cardinals the Lions the Broncos and the
Giants damn you are six three and one
overall I don't think my records ever
sorry six and one overall your math
skills are really for somebody who's a
spreadsheet and left go last week left
goes LOX let me just do some quick math
here oh and for last week's are [ __ ]
Chargers players and Patriots all did
not cover your clown he made some bunny
UN Owen for bringing you to 3 and 9 on
the season you know that was my back for
you know for calling me out for
interrupting you yesterday that was
ridiculous I didn't in a row and top
Hank I got a lot of aggression boys he
totally avoided some of the Jewish
holidays just I think it came back right
well one of us had to keep this podcast
world I was repenting for left goes yes
it was enough yeah I would need multiple
Yom Kippur to repent for left goes a few
to news on Yom Kippur ok
Tennessee signed Eric Reid I know so uh
Carolina Carolina right duck but yes so
awesome boy did they have an injury
there in Carolina where it made sense
yeah well they were they were that was
not a position of strength for them to
begin with Mike Adams is 1 starting
safety who the hell was their starting
safety to begin the year that's what I
got to think of off the top of my head
and I'm choking right now but safety has
been an issue for them or Oh Kenny not
Kenny for car you got me on Tennessee
Titans now I didn't do anything you were
doing this there on by Kenny yeah no
it's it's it's still our guy Mike Adams
who's up there in years yes and then who
Odin North Searcy that's who it Donora
Searcy did have an injury and I don't
know necessarily if they were totally
pleased with his play what was his
injury that's what I need to see why
does it matter I just would like to know
just for my further knowledge but Eric
Reid being back and it leads a great
thing I just got unfortunate news yeah
Eagles are taking a hit Rodney McCloud
out for the year CL damn starting free
safety they balance him with Malcolm
Jenkins with all the inner injuries last
year I heard focus on that yeah how big
of a deal is that
that's I mean I think he's one of the
better free safety coverage safeties in
all of football I mean as far as a
middle fielder goes his range is up
there with anybody I'd also say that of
all the injuries last year they always
had a replacement yeah
no Jordan Hicks Nigel Bratton could step
up vitai stepped up for Jason Peters all
that stuff I don't see a guy like that
on the roster I don't see another free
safety on the roster for Ronnie McCloud
I don't think I do either
Donora seriously by the way first of all
just to get that out he had two
concussions in the last 30 days so
that's why they put him on injured
reserve right and that's why Eric Reid's
there which is awesome but no I don't
think there's another guy on the roster
either and I have to pull up the roster
here because my only question is do they
move a Rasul Douglas there or because
Cory Graham ate the cat yeah okay he's
not horrible so he did sign DeAndre hall
they should be able to do some of that
DeAndre hall okay that's not a horrible
pick either yeah but they're gonna be
lacking at that position certainly are
there any more fridge and safety still
on the market not that I know of of all
the big ones that weren't signed I don't
I think Kenny Vaccaro and
were the two guys dive on branch Nate
Allen Mike Mitchell nah I wouldn't say
anything there I mean those are guys
that are you know they could fill a
roster spot maybe if you want to add
some depth depth or trust them to be
that kind of guy
sure all right huge loss not excited
about it yeah Vikings were to change my
pick on that game now serious yeah okay
you hosted this podcast today or am i
I'm waiting for you to take the hopper
let's do it Vikings ramps there's ni
football so the city already previewed
this game yesterday Vikings coming off a
27-6 lost last week to the Buffalo Bills
Rams beat the Chargers 3523 last week
Rams are a seven point favorite in this
game again already previewed this
yesterday so left go let's come to you
first for your pick and bat amount all
right so here's how I'm gonna do this
today I have a list of all the injuries
that are interesting and I have trends I
will provide the information but I'm
gonna give my pick first I'm gonna put
$100 on the Rams - seven here is why
that is a bad pick okay last year Rams
lost at Minnesota Thielen was amazing
latavius Murray was amazing and it was
jarred Goff's worst game don't like that
here's why the pick makes sense no team
flying from the central time zone to the
Pacific time zone for a Thursday game in
the last 12 years has ever won right a
team going from the central time zone in
the West West time zone oh and ten okay
that's one thing yeah - in their last
ten games as favorites the Rams are nine
and one straight up eight and two
against the spread under Zimmer in their
last seven games the Vikings as an
underdog of seven or more points they
are Owen seven the last time that
happened Pittsburgh last year week two
they lost twenty six to nine the trends
are favoring the Rams the injuries with
Everson Griffin out Dalvin cook is still
questionable the other thing too is
Riley Reef is questionable and if he
doesn't play your starting tackles for
Minnesota against that D line are Rashad
Hill and rookie Brian O'Neill which
makes me say oh crap the Rams are one of
those consistent teams
I wanted to think maybe the Vikings were
gonna keep it close but I like the rams
here even though it's minus seven yeah
okay so I will also place all right so
we know I am picking the Rams to win
this game 27 to 20
okay oh so you have a push and because
of that I'm gonna go with the team
that's a little bit more desperate in
this situation so if I have to pick one
I'm gonna pick the Vikings to cover I'm
putting $100 on your doing so you're
going Minnesota plus 7 I thought you
said you wanted Rams minus 7 no I did
not you said no wrote it right and you
crossed it out for whatever reason you
wanted to cross it out I don't know why
doing too many things he said I know
kissing on the [ __ ] shell right
worrying about your slag sound no I
don't I don't let them change the topic
keep getting I so focus Google Doc Bowie
okay I'm focused all right a soda plus 7
Minnesota yes what you said to me before
the [ __ ] is - that's why you typed out
Minnesota you guys argue too much it's
really about yes but ok I think all the
things you said concern me what's the
Rams so I mean I know what the Rams are
the Vikings right now I don't know what
they are I do still I'm trying to figure
out their offense as far as what that
full identity is going to be Dalvin cook
being there certainly is going to help
out things
Riley Reef yeah that does hurt I don't
know how much it hurts either way cuz he
wasn't that good himself last week yeah
but yeah that matchup overall favors the
Rams defensive line for sure I tell you
the trend of the central to Pacific time
zone yeah and the reason that I put a
lot of stock into that is because Zimmer
came out midweek and was like I can't
believe we have to fly to California
that's why they have no chance to win
the game I mean the fact that the coach
is making excuses on a Tuesday is very
concerning
right so you but you like desperate and
guys I just like desperate that's a
point flip to keep it closer than seven
alright I mean I'm with you on
everything you said I'm going Rams as
well though for all the listeners right
now that know who actually won this bet
I'm sure you're they're laughing at us
going Oh left goes trends are so great
meanwhile Minnesota put up 700 passing
yards all right game number two moving
on to Sunday 1:00 o'clock slate here
Jets visiting the Jacksonville Jaguars
Jaguars 2 & 1
coming off a 9 6 loss to Tennessee last
week the Jets are 1 & 2 coming off a
Thursday Night Football loss to
Cleveland spreading this game
Jacksonville - 9 Sims you'll go first
awesome ok well I think the first thing
that jumps out to me more than anything
is the fact that I do think the Jets
match up very well with the Jacksonville
Jaguars we've talked a lot about how the
Jacksonville I mean the New York Jets
they're a big physical team I would have
a hard time thinking thinking that
Jacksonville is going to push around
that defensive line out of the fact that
the Jets do have a good secondary so
they will be able to play man-to-man
when when need be but all the other
thing I like about the Jets is they play
smart zone coverages - and if you have
tells as far as where your team likes to
throw the ball at times then you know
they can drop the people into the right
zones to take away some of those staples
we talked about so much with bortles of
that office cross exactly I think they
can do things to take that away really
quick if you're watching if you're in
the New York marker to the Jacksonville
market I'm curious yeah let's count how
many deep fades there are yeah how many
shallow crosses there are right and how
many what 10-yard outs or you know
screens or bootlegs in the flat it's
like the same kind of thing it's the
same area you know either the fake to
the left and he throws to the tight end
who's on the line of scrimmage defending
him the flat or he fakes to the left and
dropped straight back and then the tight
end and a running back sneak out to
where he throws the ball yeah no doubt I
do think with the Jets offense now if
there's one weakness to the Jacksonville
defense at all is they will let you run
the football in them and the Jets have
shown the fact that they can bust some
runs from time to time the thing that
scares me more than anything is Sam
Donald on the road against this defense
I don't know where to trust him in this
situation I think the Jets do have
enough weapons and I do think they're
passing scheme fits how you pick apart
Jacksonville to his bootlegs I think
that Jeremy Bates will take some of what
he saw from Kyle Shanahan last year that
was in a quick list over the middle
right so my army baits for people that
don't realize is a Kyle he's the OC of
the Jets he's a Kyle Shanahan to site
right Kyle went out there last year yeah
a Vista rated the Jags defense yeah but
you always talk about Kyle having a
firmer grasp of the concept than anybody
else he does I don't expect Jeremy to do
it
I wondered if he could recognize some of
that and go oh I can do that I think so
I think there'll be few things he can
certainly steal from that okay okay so
I'm betting $100 on the New York Jets
I wanted to bet more yeah
we're gonna take you down to the pool
and fly our jet on top of your pool deal
with it that's great okay so this is the
thing though I wanted to go big here on
the Jets well I will say that we're
getting it at plus nine right and right
now in Vegas it's down to seven and a
half I could see that which makes me
think that Vegas is worried about the
Jets the Jets match up perfectly I am
picking Jacksonville to win this game 17
to 13 only reason I that's one thing
that stopped me from going hard this is
what a pick six exactly I could see this
game being 1310 Jaguars late in the
fourth quarter and they get a sack
fumble and a big six and they win 27 to
10 it could be anything like that
right here's the injury yeah for the
first time this season Marcus may might
play which is would be really big to see
the Jets team buster screen might not
yes and they do have athletes on the
Jaguars for net Yeldon still
questionable for net hamstring bothering
them yeah I am going 100 dollars on the
Jets let me tell you why that's a bad
pick last year when favored by seven or
more points Jacksonville was three and
OH mmm straight up and against the
spread also when you look back at the
beginning of their schedule last year
and I'm gonna pull it up right now
Jack's got a Jag schedule yeah it went
up and back blowing out a team and then
bad right which was always assigned to
me of a team that really hadn't found
themselves yet last year they beat the
Texans by 22 lose
they beat the Ravens by 30-something
right lose beat the Jaguars by 21 lose
loss of yet beat the Colts 27 nothing
yeah so and that's what we're kind of
seeing right now so the trend of the
team last year is think about it they're
a highly emotional team very athletic a
coach that keeps it simple they get
fired up after a loss that's not
do it again the reason it's a smart pick
mm-hmm
since 2010 the Jets are for no against
Jacksonville and they did beat the
Jaguars last year
do not forget though Jacksonville played
in London the week before so I think and
remember the Jets almost blew that game
to jazz ride - I'm going +9 just because
I think that the Jets have a big enough
front for at the end and I think that
the Jaguars offensive line came back to
life yeah last week right where I think
they can drop a lot of those guys in
coverage and I also think that Todd
Bowles is coaching for his frickin job
Doug Marrone is trying to keep them
focused doug morones task this year is
stop getting confident like last year it
was no one believes in us this year they
already had their Super Bowl against New
England now it's I need you to care
about the Jets Todd Bowles is coaching
for his job and I think Sam is gonna be
a little bit smart I think it's your
score is right where I had it in right
so I have $100 on the Jets which is
really scary like I'm having the same
fear as you the pick-6 I know
alright guys next game here on the one
o'clock slate the 300 Miami Dolphins
coming off a win over Oakland last week
going up to New England 1 & 2 Patriots
coming off a 26 10 loss to Detroit
spread for this game we got it at New
England - 9 and a half left go we're
gonna start with you on this game ok let
me go through the injuries yeah William
Hayes out for the year right Andre
branch also out Cameron Wake missed
Wednesdays practice with a knee injury
that D line of the Dolphins the depth
got shattered in half New England Rex
Burkhead is now on IR we are expecting
to see the debut of Josh Gordon we'll
see how it goes I am putting $100 on
Miami plus nine and a half here is why
that bet is stupid last 12 seasons with
Brady at home versus Miami New England
is 11 and oh there's seven and four
against the spread everything in the
world is going new
one's gonna blow them out the Dolphins
are a fake three-and-oh they've beaten
the Raiders they had a marathon game
against the Titans whatever that is and
then the week before they their offense
didn't really do anything and they
feasted on Sam Darnell turnovers yeah
that's why my pic is stupid why I like
my pic yes since 2015 Miami has been an
underdog of nine or more points six
times right they've won three of those
games think about that again they've
been an underdog of nine or more points
six times yet they still won three of
those games and against the spread
therefore and two they're a good
underdog team one of those happened last
year against New England right Monday
Night Football I everything in the
better mind said go New England Miami is
a horizontal speed offense with a good
Oh line if there's one team that should
be able to take advantage of the
weakness as the Patriots defense it's
this team especially if Tannehill
doesn't turn the ball over defensively
I'm scared out of my mind because Tom
Brady is going to be clicking this
weekend
Chris Hogan's gonna score I think that
Sony Michele and James White have big
days but I think I went with a team that
I'm rooting for I want the Dolphins to
send the Patriots into panic yeah I want
the Dolphins to show everybody we didn't
need Landry we didn't need Sioux we're
not a fake three-and-oh team so I'm kind
of going with my heart there which is
really dumb but I want to be on the
Dolphins side seems your breakdown than
your pick
yeah okay so I think the thing I mean
you hit on a lot of good points
certainly the Dolphins are the better
football team and my my heart one to say
go with New England cuz we've seen them
bounce back and do these things all the
time and they're gonna put on a show out
there this week I don't know if I can
they might win this football game I'm
not denying that but I don't think it's
going to be a show I don't I don't I
will just be shocked I don't think they
can transform like that in one week they
might may I know I've been wrong about
this before but everybody has I know but
I look at the Dolphins defense as suited
still to stop New England
with all those do you like that it was
improve to me that they can run the ball
on anybody so that's one thing yeah okay
maybe the pass rush is going to be an
issue but I do think the athletic
linebackers the safety play the
secondary for the Dolphins has been
transformed they're good I mean there
with Minka
Xavier Howard who we texted about
yesterday exam Ian Howard is officially
in the conversation for one of the best
corners in the sport
Baylor kid yes second round pick yeah
talked him up two years ago he's got his
big thing coming out of college was I
thought well maybe he's a little stiff
and like a step slow but you loved his
length I loved his leg but he's got he's
lost a little weight and that's the one
thing I heard about two years ago two
off seasons ago and he is the type of
guy that can match up with the Amari
Coopers or whoever it may be
man-to-man and his ball skills are off
the charts I would say other than Marcus
Peters he has the best ball skills at at
any corner in football wow he can play
it like a receiver how many times have
we seen him do it I mean the catch a
deep post two pitches the jump ball in
that game last year in Maya at the New
England game they throw the deep post
down the middle he went and ran and got
that he is like receiver ability there
so I look at also to your points the
Dolphins are tough they don't screw the
game's up to this point they play very
smart folk which is what the Patriots
feast right
the Patriots they scare me with their
secondary I can't latch onto that and
feel good about that I like picking
teams that have players that could do
extraordinary things against the Patriot
yes and the the Dolphins have four or
five guys on offense that have a hit a
seam look what Kenyan Drake did he had
almost I think he had over 200 yards of
total offense against the Patriots last
year something like that Jay keen grant
could flip the spread in one mistak yeah
what we had Mike Lombardi last week tell
us know England doesn't like when teams
do what New England does everybody else
we just spread you out throw short
passing game so because so because of
that okay I am putting $400 on the Miami
Dolphins
oh go into Miami and just like that
I'm rooting for the Patriots of all the
bets yeah to put the most money icing on
the cake I'm picking the Dolphins to win
the game 27:24 III don't see it right
now I'm gonna sorry bills only capable
of so much I might be wrong in them like
I wanted to pick the Patriots cuz of
everything but like I know what I self
evaluated picks that I've been wrong on
the last few weeks I went with this like
gut [ __ ] instead of just going wait
I always thought they were the better
team why didn't you pick that damn team
so [ __ ] my gut I'm going with my studies
and Miami's better I'm but I have one
more stat yeah there is a stat called
deaq which is defensive yards after
contact guy pretty much what it says
when i hit you how many more yards are
you getting right it really means how
many tackles are you missing and then
which teams are the most sure yeah
the Patriots ranked in DIAC at this
point of the year is what I'm gonna say
last I mean 32nd in the NFL yeah no team
is missing more tackles than the
Patriots they're slow and against the
Dolphins that could be an issue exactly
right I will say this from a betters
perspective the fact that my competitor
is putting his most money possibly yeah
on the most reliable team to bet on in
the last two decades yeah
gives me a little bit a little bit I
know but at the same point man I I can't
make these left Cole ox I can't go up
alright guys my just can't I can't hang
my hat on New England right now I just
can't do it like my football their past
events sucks their run defense sucks I
mean it all saw so I looked at the
Patriots schedule from last year and I
go what is the game where it all flipped
right where they they beat the Texans
they outlast and then they they lose to
the Panthers and they outlast the Bucs
and they outlast the Jets and then it
was that Sunday night Falcons game where
that was the game where I felt like they
went in there and flipped it yeah and
I'm looking at their calendar I believe
October 4th is that a Sunday
Sunday night against the Colts and
though that's a Thursday night against
the Colts I don't think they're gonna be
right by then
I think it's then the next Sunday night
hosting Kansas City right I think they
were right last year we're not you're
just not giving them credit from the
Kansas City was good so with the
Carolina Panthers they went to the free
contestants which is Sean this team this
year I'm gonna go okay you beat the
crappy Texans who haven't played a good
game yet you know I mean that's just I
just I will never I know I will never be
on camera saying the Patriots dynasty is
dead I'm not [ __ ] find me ever saying
that now and we can run this back in
eight weeks when they're like three and
five but I'm just saying right now I am
NOT being one of those people all right
guys next game here Philadelphia at
Tennessee spread this game we just heard
rodney McLeod's out philadelphia - three
Eagles coming off a 20 to 16 win over
the Colts Titans coming off a nine to
six win over Jacksonville Sims we're
gonna start with you in this game
Philadelphia - 3 ok Philadelphia - 3 I
am going to bed
$40 Josh hold on oh yeah this ministry
the line now in Vegas is up to - for
what are you doing I'm picking the
Philadelphia Eagles correct for $40
correct [ __ ] know what a Titan is so
you're not gonna kill an eagle I know
that not with your sword you can't throw
it up there I don't know man they could
have one of those thoughts I don't think
it's Blake bortles throwing the sword
and it's not the worst ward Thor sword
Thor sword Thor sword nice arse what's
your analysis ok my analysis is this
this matchup does scare me
ok that's why I'm betting only $40 I'm
picking the eagles to win the game 21 to
17 I think these are the things that
concern me right off the bat I'm scared
for the Eagles offense especially their
past game it's gonna it scares me
against this bunch
Tennessee not only we've talked about
the secondary being talented but they
are the type of team that can play
percentages as far as what you're doing
on the offensive pass game and drop
people in the right area and I think at
times you're passing offense is a little
predictable about where people are it's
on Carson wants to make the big plays
which I think he can he can do obviously
because I'm picking them to win the game
but the Titans run defense is really
what scares me and I think that's gonna
be the big thing to watch for the game
right can the Eagles dominate the line
of scrimmage in the run game if they can
there's gonna put them in prime position
to win the football game and maybe they
win by more than four or five or
whatever it may be but if it's like Dan
the run games kind of inconsistent I
think this game can end up being an
absolute nail-biter I think that the
Titans offense I expect Mariota to be a
little bit better certainly the Titans
should not be able to run the ball but I
think they could have some success
passing the ball to a degree with tricks
there's aggressive as your defenses at
times but I think when I just all comes
down to it I'm picking I'm picking it's
a close one but I'm picking the Eagles
in Carson Wentz just because it's Carson
Wentz and I don't trust Mariota in this
type of football game did you hear how
uncertain he was I did yes did you hear
all of the things he said that probably
should have led him to picking the
Tennessee Titans I did hear all of that
yes and I wrote one thing too just sorry
I brought eCos pasty not great but I
don't think the Titans are gonna be able
take advantage of enough to overcome it
injury wise yeah jack-jack Conklin could
be back on Sunday Philadelphia Alshon
Jeffery is cleared not sure if he's
playing right a giant Sproles or
day-to-day we'll see if they play and as
I mentioned before Ronnie McCloud the
centerfielder on that defense is out
yeah I am betting $100 on the Tennessee
Titans
now you are bow down to me
you will stand there and understand my
strength the Titans are back no down
creation I he here's why that is a bad
pick it is a bad pick because the Eagles
have the better quarterback the Eagles
have the better align the Eagles have
the better D line and the Eagles as a
whole are a better team that's why it's
a bad pick here's why it's a good pick
there is not a single player on the
Eagles other than maybe a galore that
could go deep and I mean like take a
short pass and go deep because what you
said earlier this could be a nail-biter
yeah if it's a nail-biter I'm taking the
home team plus three points I get the
home team with a good field goal kicker
and you're giving me three points if
it's a nail-biter then I want the three
points okay there's a few guys I want
Carson Wentz I get it I took look you
know I get it in their last eight games
at home the Titans are seven and one
this is this has turned into a
home-field advantage out of nowhere yeah
in the last four years the Eagles have
been a favorite of three or more points
on the road nine times they are three
and six they are two and seven against
the spread including that this week two
against the Tampa Bay Buccaneers as an
Eagles fan I have seen many times
the Eagles being favored going into a
road game and letting a team hanging
around with them for two three quarters
yeah what I saw last week against the
Colts is what the Eagles season is going
to be it is gonna be a grinder where
their defense doesn't let you score in
the red zone which is they've done all
year and it's Carson Wentz putting
together 15 plagiarise 17 play drives
just like I'm afraid of the Bucks
inability to put together a drive and
the reliance on the deep ball I'm afraid
of the Eagles in a
to score from 30 yards out yeah 40 yards
out I don't see that right now and the
problem is is all these 15-yard drives
are great but they're ending in field
goals and I don't see the game player
they lost Mike Wallace he was replacing
Torrey Smith Torrey Smith was their deep
shot guy yeah they don't have that right
now because of that it's gonna be a
close game so I'm going with the home
team that's good at home with the points
all right guys how do you feel after I
said all that no III mean I think this
was a Ghia game that I would never bet
on I would never bet on my thing with I
think they're going to be better in the
red zone this week though remember when
I texted you last week like red zone not
perfect like tough for Carson was your
first game that stuffed your first game
back that's where he is magical
I just couldn't when it all came down to
it I mean you're gonna bet a Mario hell
I just can't trust that pass offense
right now I get everything I think my
one thing will be will the Titans get
pressure because the Colts got some
pressure on Carson Wentz yeah and you've
been every time I listen to you talking
about Tennessee you've been very
impressed with their pass rush I'm just
curious how it's gonna be me to next
game on the early slate here guys oh and
three Houston desperate on the road
going to visit the Colts in Indianapolis
this game is a pick'em for us Wow left
go we'll go to you first let me go see
if the odds have changed currently is
the Colts are favored by one injuries
yeah Bruce Ellington quietly put on IR
so now Houston's looking at will fuller
you know himself is you never know
what's gonna happen him week to week and
DeAndre Hopkins yeah their slot guy is
Kiki Cote yeah what yeah I mean I don't
even know I cannot know what to say to
you about him so it's scary for Indy
Jack Doyle is out again right Eric Ebron
is questionable we know how much tight
ends matter do you new else's
questionable name is practice both
starting safeties Malik hooker Clayton
gathers mm-hmm it's enormous
yeah especially against a team that has
will fuller just to be real because will
fuller still makes place Costanzo again
missed practice I am going to be putting
$100 on the cold
the hell is koti for that kid hundred
dollars in the cult's hundreds in the
coast no right for my tell ya that's
cold right there that coats gonna make
my farm a lot of money you ever seen a
movie War Horse I can plow a field with
that coat come over here a little horsey
come over here do you see the mane I do
see that do you see the legs yes oh stop
talking here Cole T alright here's the
reason why it's a dumb pic there's a lot
of injuries on the Colts and the Houston
Texans have an explosive offense that
began to show itself in the second half
of last week and JJ Watt had three sacks
in the second half and it could click at
any time and if there's one team that's
more desperate it's the Houston Texas
yes bill O'Brien's but is as tight as
what I'm not gonna answer that question
and I will ask you to continue your
announcer okay
it's as tight as Cameron's but in Ferris
Bueller where you could stick a lump of
coal up yes and pull out a diamond
perfect good job well done here's the
reason why it's great nice job Simms the
Texans have lost how many games in a row
Sims what does it know oh nine from last
year they've lost nine in a row right do
you know what the record is against the
spread in those nine games cuz again you
could lose the game but still cover the
spread
yeah one in eight Wow in their last 12 1
and 11
I am so this is a team that's not just
losing they're losing bad right also
Indy one of the themes this week is
there certain teams that just run
through their division in their last 8
11 games against Houston India is one
eight of them Indy against the AFC South
they just have their number I said this
after the game on Sunday
Indy is a well coached team India is a
team with a good interior offensive line
and yeah they get beat sometimes but
Andrew Luck kind of has time back there
yeah Marlin Mac may be back I like the
way that their team looks they really
did have the ball deep in the eagle zone
they just couldn't punch it in and I
like some of the
athletes on their defense I like India
as a football team and I'm done betting
on Houston I just don't want online and
if it's a pick'em and I don't even have
to give away points yeah I'm gonna go
with Indy yeah ten dollars in the Colts
okay I'm taking the Colts to win the
game 23 to 20 it's a pick'em Nicki G's
giving you the sound effects no matter
how much you bet this no I like it Thank
You Nicki I was not expecting that
I'm begging them there at home it's
Andrew Luck and I have no faith in the
Texans yeah the Texans they come around
every week in the second half yes that's
what they are right now so I don't trust
them for four quarters of football no no
keep going I have some question if so I
think that's one thing I look at I just
got to see it to believe it what the
Texas more than anything I do think the
Colts D is sneaky good they don't beat
themselves they usually have a pretty
good game plan there's a few creative
blitzes on a weekly basis that I go okay
and let me just see what else I wrote
there and you know I I think the Texans
D okay the pass rush has not been
anything I understand JJ Watt is coming
along and he's a force like there's no
he's close to being back in like an
absolute game wrecker but I don't trust
anybody in the back end for the use of
Texans easy either I think that's the
other thing that scares me and they've
had a lot of injuries I know and the
Colts don't have anything special on the
offensive side of the ball
other than T Y Hilton but I think they
still have enough between Andrew Luck
the decently creative offense the tight
end play and the rat who screams - and
I'm not just I'm just not gonna trust a
Houston Texans in this game that's why
I'm betting ten dollars Texans are a
desperate football team who I do think
are slightly more talented yes
but I'm picking the Colts at home my
prediction is that Nayeem Heinz has a
long touchdown this week I don't know
why I'm saying that my question for you
is this there are two teams this year
that I wish they were playing in each
other because I'd love to make a bet
yeah
the Raiders always start off strong and
always die out in the second half right
the Texans always start off bad and
always come forward in the second half
yeah Texans perspective is Bill O'Brien
being out coached during the week and is
a better adjuster yeah I have not been
pressed with really an overall game
party game yeah so right or is he just a
really good adjuster
yeah he's a good adjuster to a degree
it's not mind blowing he's pretty
stubborn of what he wants to do in the
first half of a football game and then
they've been so you know just inadequate
at moving the ball or doing anything
consistently that he comes out in the
second half and they have a different
approach altogether yeah I their
offensive line as an issue the kid left
tackle Rankin's is a big time issue that
scares me I don't think they're ever
gonna be this consistently scary run
team yes and I'm just I got to see
Watson perform four four cores he makes
a dumb dumb mistake or two every week I
just want to say this really quick one
of my big things about the Colts the
last two years no team has entered the
fourth quarter more with a lead and then
blown it right
think about the construct of the way
these two teams plays I would totally
not be surprised if the fourth quarter
the Colts are up 21 10 and then here
comes Watson will the Colts be able to
hold on I think they will especially cuz
it's at home yeah I do I think Holmes a
big thing alright guys next game on the
early slate here Buffalo Bills at the
Green Bay Packers Buffalo coming off a
27-6 win over the Vikings last week
Green Bay 1 1 & 1 after losing to
Washington in week 3 Green Bay a 10 and
a half point favorite in this game left
go we'll start with you for this one ok
first I want to hammer home how crazy
last week was when there when they went
over the Vikings the bills became the
first team since 1995 that's 23 years to
win a game where they were underdogs of
17 or more right the first team in 23
years so what we saw last week was crazy
injury-wise LeSean McCoy has come out
the media and said I will play granted
he's been wearing a non-contact jersey
at practice but he's still gonna play
right Jimmy Graham didn't practice for
Green Bay Mohammad Wilkerson out for the
year
for a team that only had three good
defensive linemen and I don't wanna say
that was a big defensive line that were
impactful right
losing 33% of that is a big deal Brian
Belaga was limited in practice this week
he only played 28 snaps against
Washington
he started the game yeah but he didn't
play the whole game and it probably led
to Rogers having to run more on a bum
knee I'm going to be putting $100 on
Green Bay - ten and a half okay here is
why that is stupid their last five home
games against teams from the AFC against
the spread Green Bay is one and four
okay here is why it's smart Buffalo
hasn't won in Green Bay since 1991
that's one in their last 8 September
home games against the spread Green Bay
is six and two but here's the one that
really hammered it home for me since
Rogers took over Green Bay has been
favored by 10 or more points 23 times
straight up
they've won 21 of them hmm so when
they're favored by a lot Rogers gets the
win right against the spread though it's
a frickin coin flip yeah 12 and 10 10
and a half points is a lot
I just came through and I went what's
more likely
Buffalo goes on the Run Road gets a huge
emotional win with a rookie quarterback
and then the next week battles it close
with another team or do their emotion
somewhat subside and they collapse a
little bit and that Aaron Rodgers after
you came away on this is a pick solely
based off of your reads you left the
Buffalo game and went very still suck
they still captured two turnovers by
Kirk Cousins in their own zone and they
built on that and I still don't expect
them to be good and the other side you
went Green Bay had so many opportunities
against Washington and they let it slip
right when I see a team that just lost
and they should have won and a team that
had an emotional win yeah I think Green
Bay covers ten and a half yeah okay I'm
with you there totally III think that I
look at it like this I think this game
can be somewhat closed for a little
while Josh I'm going to put $100 on the
Green Bay Packers thanks Chris okay I
like the Packers to win this game 27 14
something like that I do think that the
bills are the bills defense McDermott is
going to be all over this office Green
Bay he's just too smart it has too many
tells in their offensive scheme as is so
he's gonna have the right people in the
right areas then don't play man a whole
lot but we've always talked about he's a
master when he can kind of figure out
your passing scheme of where to drop the
people in the right way only thing I'll
say of this the Packers have a good
enough short passing game and it's Aaron
Rodgers to where I think he'll still be
able to be surgical into some of these
quick zone windows I think that'll keep
him going so the other matchup I look at
patent day ball it's New England versus
the Jets back in the day it's a little
bit of a you know paedon understands
what day ball wants to do on the
offensive side of the ball
he understands the base scheme of that
offense in general out of the fact that
he has really nothing to worry about on
the edge of that team as far as a
receiver or anything scary
I do like I'll tell you who I do like
you like pet and more than Zimmer I I
like yeah I like petting more than I'm
saying well never couldn't do it well
yeah okay I mean Zimmer
again is up against right two turnovers
and the fact in the fact that I do think
that the Packers defense is gonna look
at it and go well we can't let this kid
run around like this either so they'll
be a little more conscious than
Minnesota was on third down but they're
double a gap guys who then couldn't get
out of the pocket do you think clay
Matthews gets another roughing the
passer gosh I hope not I think this is
the week it will change I think the NFL
is took enough crap and the officials
are hearing that do you think Josh Allen
is huge right remember what I said
yeah Alex Smith and Kirk Cousins might
get the calls Josh Allen might not
because he's big yes all right so wait
there was another guy I want to talk
about and I'm I got a pull oh the kid
I'll tell you the one kid to watch out
for him on the bills that can be
dangerous as far as a down field threat
if they play man-to-man and they played
this kid number 16 Robert Foster or too
many times rookie from Alabama just
watch out he is one guy on their team
that can run by people and Josh Allen
can throw the ball like the guy from
Napoleon Dynamite literally over the
Montana Mountains but I think Rob's a
rubber foster have any like targets left
he did he had some big targets it got P
I and I don't know if he had an actual
catch but he was
behind Minnesota t2 different eyes I
know so that could be one let me just
see if he could hook him up Teemo Dale
Rogers say targets but he didn't get any
catches okay but either way I think that
was the end of my evaluation there I
just think the Packers have enough of a
short pass yeah I can see this game
being like 22:14 Rodgers mix brings them
down on one more surgical drive to put
it away with four minutes left in the
game and they win 2714 all right guys
next game here we're going Detroit at
Dallas to one and two teams here spread
for this game Cowboys - three and a half
Sims we're gonna start with you on this
one
Cowboys - three and a half okay let me
get to my notes here pull the team's
polo teams order this week well I
followed the NFL Jesus schedule that's a
mistake so that's where your emails fine
here we go I am betting $100 Joshua on
the Detroit Lions okay I want some dumb
Cowboys Roy stop shooting animals that
are endangered thank you good
clarification thank you listen that's
I'm not against guns they're not my
favorite thing just clarifying but I
don't want rare animals shot especially
big cats okay how'd you break down again
oh how about okay okay all right so this
is I don't know what to say about this
game there are so many things where
there's questions in this game I guess
to me a little bit okay
Lions deep run defense it's the worst in
football and it's the Dallas Cowboys I
know and they had success run again see
I know I know they did but I also look
at I look at Detroit and I think they
might have figured out their defense
last week so I am going to play the fact
that the way they looked with a Shaun
Robinson and his second game playing in
this new scheme with Patricia cuz he
wasn't even active for Game one against
the New York Jets DeSean hand in the
middle our man Jared Davis I think that
they've truly might have figured out
this defense to a degree I do I think
the Cowboys will run on the run on them
yes but I don't think it's gonna be a
free-for-all where they're just gonna
run them over I think the front seven
from Detroit's a little better than I
gave it credit for okay
now the Jets of 49ers they did run the
ball oh I know all over them right and
and then even in the 49er game there was
some good moments of dim they're doing
okay against Kyle's run scheme and then
Brito found a ski a little seam and
broke it but the other thing that I
think you have to take into account here
is when they played those teams now the
Jets game was a little different cuz
they got in the hole so early but they
had to actually worry about people in
the past game and they actually had to
worry about a past scheme that was like
dangerous there ain't [ __ ] to worry
about here with the Dallas Cowboys pass
game so that's going to take less of the
pressure off this Detroit defense to
where they can go huh we can put a few
more eggs in the stop the run basket so
I just don't trust that now the Dallas
d-line the Dallas defense it's very good
it really is I don't think the Dallas D
line is going to be able to ruin this
football game like they ruin most
football games and I do think that this
Detroit defensive run game is going to
continue because I think Matt Patricia
wants it to continue he wants to play
this style of football and we saw the
Chris Carson had a little running
ability last week beyond Seattle so I
think they're gonna be able to run the
ball enough to where I think this is a
very ugly football game and I'm going to
pick Detroit to win the game 1714
straight up Ezekiel on submiss practice
he's also missed the last James shots
what was his status he would miss prank
I know but it was a questionable is
there any status a commission yeah Shawn
Lee is out I am putting $100 on Detroit
and I think they're winning too here's
why we're wrong we are wrong because
since dak has started when the Cowboys
are favored by three or more they're
eight and two in their last eight games
as favorites the Cowboys are seven and
one straight up here's why we're right
right the last five games Dallas is
average less than 12 points per game yes
okay right also since 2015 and the main
reason I'm picking Detroit the Cowboys
without Shawn Lee are one in seven we've
talked about this every year when Shawn
Lee's not there that
defense falls off a cliff probably why
they drafted Layton Vander Esch probably
why they have a lot of hopes on Jaylon
Smith yeah I look at this and my biggest
fear is it Zeke its Zeke its Zeke
I am afraid of Matt Stafford on the road
I'm a lot happier that he's in a dome
something about him in a dome yeah they
have a good secondary in Dallas but
there's a lot of good weapons on this
Detroit offense that I think I expect
those receivers crossing up right where
Sean Lee should be and I just think when
there's no threat of a passing attack I
look at the big guys in the middle for
Detroit the to Alabama goes hand and
Robin's right and it's speed at
linebacker yeah I just have to hope that
they don't get pushed over but three and
a half I think Detroit's a better
football team than them yeah I did I am
trying to remove the weak one from my
brain yes right the Jets game the Jets
aren't that team anymore and Detroit's
not that team anymore but Detroit
against San Francisco they were a
freight train in the second half on
offense and the defense got it done and
against New England they were I mean it
was only close because it was New
England and New England does an amazing
job of mitigating losses they're great
at going now we're gonna take a timeout
here we're gonna scheme something up
here
I think Detroit wins this game and I
think the Cowboys are in free fall I'm
with you yeah all right yes next game on
the one o'clock slate here Tampa Bay
visiting Chicago Tampa Bay on the short
week at this is a tough a Monday Night
Football lost to the Steelers Bears
coming off a close win against the
Cardinals last week 16 to 14 and the
spread for this game that we have
Chicago - one and a half this line has
moved to three but Chicago - one and a
half it's moved to Chicago - three
correct yes Wow all right injuries
Chicago he's picking the bear he's
picking the book Amukamara and Marcus
Cooper senior did not practice Wednesday
we have injured corners for Chicago
obviously it was the other one beside
him look at Marcus Cooper Marga scooper
okay
Tampa Bay you know that Chris Conte is
on IR that means three rookie defensive
backs are now starting for the Bucs and
Hargreaves is out all that stuff
Britain Grimes is banged up beau Allen
is out Vita veía is still not practicing
fully and Gerald McCoy right now has a
biceps injury and dachshund is limited
in practice for the Bucks I went back
and forth on this a million times and I
settled on Chicago for $100 Josh last
year sounds just like a lion it does not
know it does that last year the Bucks
embarrassed the Bears but that was also
Mike Glennon's bears 29 to 7 the last 10
road games for the Bucks they are 2 and
8 this is in my mind the first real road
test for Ryan Fitzpatrick
there's something about a road team in
New Orleans where I go it's the New
Orleans Saints aren't that good in New
Orleans and when you're in a dome it's
tough so this is outside Soldier Field
and I think we're gonna see a little bit
of the first half Ryan Fitzpatrick
however with those corner injuries I
could totally see them going out here's
why I'm wrong yeah I'm wrong because I
have no faith in Mitchell's for Biscay
right outside of the first two drives of
the first half and then the second half
that the Tampa Bay Bucs could score at
any moment and put a lot of pressure on
an offense that I don't have faith in
against a Bucs D line that I think has
actually been very very good yeah the
reason that I'm going with Chicago I
think that they're a team that probably
got their ass ripped all week after
their performance against Arizona and
they're facing a Bucs team that just
played on Monday night that probably is
exhausted there's a distraction with
Jameis Winston in there and they're
going to a Chicago defense that if
there's one guy that I have faith in to
make the Bears the Bucs run the ball
it's Vic Fangio and I like the Bears I
think they're the better football team
yeah I'm going a hundred dollars on the
Bears as well Josh Roy me want
Buccaneers
ah [ __ ] your eye patch gonna swallow
that [ __ ] too okay here we go oh
don't shoot a bear with a cannon that's
mean I feel like there's definitely a
video of that online well I got like an
old circus bear taking a cannon to the
chest kinda games I'm picking bears to
win this game 24 to 20 the first thing
is this is the best team the Bucks have
played this year as a whole I'm saying
that yeah yeah the Saints idea I'm
saying right now as far as the way
they're playing I do think the Eagles
yeah I am as far as everything together
yes your Eagles offense was struggling
at that time yep I think the Bears
defense is certainly the best defense
they've played I think that's for sure
that's it's gonna give it this hardest
time and when Vic Fangio their run
defense is good as is but when they
don't have to worry about stopping the
run at all then watch out and this is a
team that doesn't live in man-to-man
either way so I don't think you have to
worry about that too much left go as far
as like the matchups down the field
there they're a they're a sometimes
we'll throw you off by playing
man-to-man typo football team right and
the kid Callahan's a pretty good corner
I think he'll would be the one that
probably fills in for a mu Kamara so
that would be my my two cents there now
to the other side of the ball the Bucks
defense it's not good and I understand
the Bears defense hasn't been perfect
yet our offense hasn't been perfect yet
but there's things I like about the
Bears offense still I think mature
Brisky will come come around I don't
think this is a thing where I look at it
and go oh he's really the issue with the
team he's had a few dumb moments I'm not
gonna deny that but I still think with
their scheme this is the best run team
that they've played yet to this degree
because the but the but this is a legit
or percent downhill run football
tomorrow with the Saints is not a
downhill running no and they were go
sign the Eagles were a jogging the game
I haven't put out smallwood and all that
stuff pittsburgh didn't even try to run
no they didn't have to right so I just
look at it from that to where they're
also gonna be able to I think control
the clock I think true Brisky like I'm
saying will come around and continue in
pice smarter football they win that game
last week by 17 points if they don't
just dig themselves into the hole early
on and I'm going with the Bears because
of that all right - thing next game here
hold on Josh we got you know what's
about to happen
what
to happen Oh
the alarms up Ryan Fitzpatrick's about
to turn back into a pumpkin we've all
been it's all been a ruse it's over
Cincinnati at Atlanta next game here
bangles bangles are 2 & 1 or the bangles
if you are Chris Sims after losing the
Panthers Wiggles bangles
sorry Falcons are 1 & 2 after a 4337
loss of the Saints last week spread in
this game Atlanta - five and a half Sims
you can start ok alright so for this
football game as a good joke laughter I
am going to place a hundred dollars on
the Cincinnati Bengals how dare you is
that Nevis seriously how dare you do
that to a bangle they're a fierce animal
and they're roaming wild all over the
city of Cincinnati and eating chili and
spaghetti yes okay so my big thing is
the bangles bangles are a good football
team they're not a horrible football
team but I have questions about them the
Atlanta Falcons the only they're a good
football team as well I mean they got
two tough losses and two tough football
games that could have gone either way
really uh I am worried I am worried
about the Atlanta Falcons secondary a
little bit I mean yeah I mean those two
safeties going down that's the Nardo
Allen and Keon O'Neal who so I'm Dion G
yeah I worry about all that I really do
I think the big thing with me with the
Cincinnati Bengals is I just don't trust
them I don't trust Andy Dalton on the
road and I just don't think there's
enough of a pass rush and speed in that
front seven to Atlanta to disrupt what
the Bengals want are yes what the
Bengals want to do offensively and I
think my biggest thing here and I think
that the Falcons are going to win this
game I just don't think it's a five and
a half points is a little much the
balcony balconies are gonna be yeah the
Bengals are gonna be somewhat desperate
but so were the Falcons I think this is
a close football game but I think that
really the big difference for me is the
Falcons offense in this matchup
you know Cincinnati the way they got run
on
last week and I know the Falcons didn't
run the ball all that well themselves
last week but I I just think the Falcons
are going to be able to move the ball in
the Cincinnati defense I think it's who
are you picking them I picked them to
cover the spread but I'm picking the
Falcons to win the football game 31 to
28 I think it will go back and forth
like that I'm just gonna put my really
in a closed football game that's a coin
flip I'm gonna go with Maddie ice
because Maddie ice has balled out the
last few weeks and Calvin Ridley has
showed me that you I don't care who you
are you better be careful playing him
man-to-man and now they have two guys
like that so that's why I go there
injuries AJ Green did not play the
second half against Carolina yeah he is
said he's ready to go
revenue assange right yeah he was banged
up but that's probably why the Bengals
offensive ell off am at it did some good
signs for them signs are saying it's
close to returning for Joe Mixon and
senator Billy price which is a different
dynamic for that Bengals team Atlanta
banged up Ricardo Allen out you already
mentioned you already know about Deon
Jones and Keyon O'Neal Kazee Justin
Bethel and Brian Poole are all banged up
they're all on the injury report for
Atlanta so it's there are guys that are
out and their replacements are all
banged up and questionable right Devonta
Freeman took part in the walk through
this week which is great for the Odell
rogers fantasy team we'll see how he
plays I am gonna be putting $100 on the
Bengals plus five and a half here is why
that is stupid
against the NFC since 2016 this includes
last week against the Panthers the
Bengals are 2 5 & 1 they do not have a
good record against the NFC here's why
it's smart Falcons and their last six
against the AFC one in five straight up
Owen six against the spread and they
were favorites in five of those six so
their favorites in five of six games
against the AFC one one of them beat
none of them against the spread under
Dan Quinn when the Falcons are favored
by five or more there's been 17 games
there five and twelve against the spread
I look at this team and go Matt Ryan has
been bawling but
how have they gotten their big place
Philadelphia deep throws to Julio Jones
second week Carolina a few more deep
throws to Julio Jones New Orleans man
they were all deep throws cincinnati has
the corners where if that ball goes up I
have just as much faith in Dre
Kirkpatrick as I do Calvin Ridley if I'm
putting that out I hear you I also go
ooh
Carolina's pass-rush on a fast turf sign
me up
that sounds great the deal I'm and
getting a run side-to-side I really like
a lot yeah I am a little bit of a
Carolina I meant Cincinnati the the
Cincinnati offense
I saw Andy Dalton in a dome against Indy
I like the way it looked
I kind of like the way it's gonna look
in Atlanta I think that Atlanta had
familiarity with New Orleans and I think
they had familiarity with Carolina two
NFC South teams this is an Atlanta team
that last year blew a game against
Buffalo and lost it early in the year
blew a game against Miami early in the
year I think Atlanta beats up teams they
know and I think they lose to teams that
they don't know I like Cincinnati here
and I like I think five and a half us
too big if it was Atlanta - three I'd
think about it
I think five and a half team I think
Cincinnati's a more talented team it is
gonna come down to though can Matt Ryan
ball I just think he's gonna have to
ball to win by three not ball to win by
seven that's pretty much what I came
down to as well all right guys moving
into the four I didn't even plan to talk
about Miami and Buffalo just popped in
my head but think about that land that's
kind of who they are they I always say
they dominate the NFC South yes they do
and and Dan Quinn has gone from they
took Atlanta I think if I remember right
before Dan Quinn got there they
dominated matchups in which they faced
teams that they never faced and they
lost their rivals and now split around
which is a very Seattle Seahawks to do
which I'll bring up in this very next
pick so moving on to the late games here
the late afternoon Seattle visiting
Arizona Seahawks 1 and 2 coming off a
win against the Cowboys last week
Cardinals oh and 3 after losing to the
Bears Seattle a three
favorite in this game left go will go to
notable wide receiver injuries here
Seattle Doug Baldwin back at practice
Pete Carroll feeling hopeful hopeful he
may play Arizona Larry's been battling a
hamstring injury now for the last few
weeks and both of those guys
I expect to play because that's just who
those guys are I am going to be going
with Seattle for $100 I don't have a
reason this is stupid I just don't
I know it's Seattle on the road and
they're a much better team at home and
Seattle's not that good this year
Arizona has 20 points for the year yeah
here we were talking about Dallas oh
they only averaged 12 a game in three
games Arizona has 20 points that game
last week was given to them in a gift
wrap proflowers.com promo code 90% off
by the way you get free chocolate
covered strawberries and you also get a
kiss at the door and they still blew it
yes last 11 NFC west road games for
Seattle they're eight two and one
straight up they're seven three and one
against the spread Seattle against their
rivals I love it
Michael Dixon is gonna put the ball in
the five yard line and here comes Ricky
quarterback Josh Rosen and Seattle's
gonna be sitting there going please
throw it please I'm going Seattle
straight up I just I just don't like the
Arizona Cardinals and I think the
beginning of the year against their
divisional opponents I like Seattle yeah
I don't think this is rocket science
this is $100 on the Seattle Seahawks the
lot of similar bets the Cardinals have
the worst offense in football and it's
not even close like it's the worst Josh
Rosen is gonna be helped to this but
it's the worst there so yeah I think
they can move the ball a little bit
because Seattle's defense is nothing
special this year but I think the other
thing that scares me maybe more than
that is the fact that the Cardinals
can't stop the run so that is what
really scares me at least we can round
about 32 times exactly with Chris Carson
at 30
you carries himself so they run the ball
even more than that right and it seemed
like Wilson Schottenheimer and Carroll
for the first time were on the same page
of a tempo this is only talked about I
know well it mean it sounded like Pete
Carroll was stopping them from running
the ball the first two weeks he kind of
admitted that last week leading up into
the game Seattle Schottenheimer the
reason I thought they hired him is to
run the football
he had the years they went to the AFC
championship game with Mark Sanchez
who's no russell wilson they were I
think led the NFL in rushing one year
the other year they were number five in
football running the football
so I think from that right there and it
is the Seattle Seahawks and they still
have Russell Wilson and a few other key
pieces that I like that yes I got to
pick them to win this football game I
have them winning 24 17 on the road we
set all offseason yeah I still have
faith in the the Seahawks because
Russell Wilson's their quarterback and
Pete Carroll's their coach and the
defense I think has far exceeded
everyone's expectations think about who
they've played Denver on the road in
Denver von Miller good defense yeah on
the road national television Chicago
Khaleel Mack good defense at home Dallas
great defensive line super underrated
defense yes and now they're playing
Arizona right like Arizona get their run
game going that's gonna be the big thing
if they want to win the game they gotta
have a steady dose of David John Arizona
doesn't even know Arizona's beyond not
knowing their identity
they're schizophrenic and they don't
know which one to go to right they got
ten different personalities they stink
at stopping the run too just to add that
so you know that they're these are two
of the worst run stopping defenses in
football but I don't think it's gonna
matter as much for I don't think so yeah
all right guys moving on here next I
think you Frank Clark this will be my
bold prediction yeah Frank Clark causes
a turnover that puts that like is a huge
momentum shifter he's going bold
Cleveland
yeah haven't it's been a while since
we've had to do bold predictions back
god Cleveland at Oakland next game here
Browns one one and one after Thursday
night football against the Jets yes
Raiders oh and three after losing in the
Dolphins last week this is a pick'em in
Oakland left go we'll start with you do
you know how disrespectful it is that a
team
hasn't won a road game since 2015 is
being called a pick'em the Browns have
lost 22 road games in a row and Vegas
has them as three-point favor yeah
that's so disrespectful yeah
Emanuel Agbo will play all of a sudden
the Cleveland offensive line is going to
be even crazier yes Donald Penn and PJ
Hall offensive tackle defensive tackle
expected to play for Oakland I am
putting $100 on the Raiders second week
in a row just win baby second week in a
row and go with the Raiders the Browns
in that 22 game losing streak are six 15
and one against the spread here is the
main reason I'm picking the Raiders
other than the fact that Cleveland has
no idea how to handle themselves off of
a win and Jon Gruden is going I'm Owen
three and if anything bad happens I'm
going to kill you in the last 15 years
Simms yeah ten quarterbacks have been
taken with the number one overall pick
how do you think they fared in their
starts 10 guys taking the last 15 years
with the number one pick in the draft
their first start how does the team do
oh I'm gonna say it's like 1 in 9 wrong
oh and 10 whoa there oh and 10 straight
up right there oh and 10 against the
spread right Baker may feel would have
to shatter a historic trend I'm going
Raiders all right this is a tough one ok
I'm betting $10 on this ok and I'm
taking the Cleveland Browns thanks I get
it dog pound
not scared of you Raiders ah um okay it
is a tough one and I wouldn't expect
anybody to bet on this football game
because I think it's a total coin flip
and it can go any which direction I
think the big thing for me more than
anything is the Browns are the better
football team from top to bottom
the Browns both teams run defense scares
me a little bit okay to where I go okay
that's one determining factor I can look
at and go who what would you do here all
right so what run offense do I like the
most okay that's where I go I think
Cleveland's run offense it's pretty damn
good I mean they can run the ball they
can do different things also to the fact
that I think they're gonna play an
offensive style that the Raiders won't
be ready for it and we in week four here
because I think you're gonna see a
combination of Todd Haley Ben
Roethlisberger Pittsburgh offense with
some under the center traditional runs
Baker Mayfield bootlegs and things like
that because he can do those things that
Ben couldn't do in the Todd Haley
offense and they didn't even try them so
I think that plays into their advantage
too
I know the Raiders play tough every week
they really do and they're in the
football game and the common logic is to
say that they're at home and they're
desperate I get that
I think the Browns are not gonna be
flying high over the fact that they
finally want a football game I still
think I don't just because they're the
Browns and they've been [ __ ] on your
finger Straker Mayfield is the savior
and they finally got a win in the Bud
Light cases were open across him and he
and Hugh Jackson has shown you that he
really knows how to temper expectations
I get that I'm Hugh Jackson after a win
probably gave out popsicles and says
take the day off proud of you guys I
don't know about all that I still think
they have Todd Haley and Greg Williams
okay I do like Paul Gunther and the
things he's done for that Raiders
football team but damn they can let up
some big fat big plays too I know that
they do some things at times like you
know having Marcus Gilchrist trying to
cover Kenny Stills man-to-man on a
40-yard corner route for a touchdown
like sorry you deserve to lose when you
do stupid crap like that I don't know
what else to say to you there
the Raiders have found ways to mess up
football games hey is is III don't Milo
I just realized I went 23 20 Browns
alright 23:21 brats I'm going Baker
Mayfield has a beautiful game game when
he drive and Derek Carr to this point
has been good for a dumb mistake in
every football game here's my last thing
I want to say there's a lot of people
that talk to me about betting in game or
betting half's if I'm betting a half
here this is how I do this I'm betting
the Raiders in the first half and I'm
betting the Browns in the second half
Browns down 21 to the Steelers comeback
started slow Saints losing the entire no
no they were up that game but their
offense was stagnant Jets down 14
nothing comeback the Raiders always
start fast especially at home the Browns
thus far I started slow I wanted to come
after the Browns and go what offensive
lines have they faced as good as the
Raiders I mean they faced Big Ben and
the Steelers Drew Brees and the Saints
like they're not letting up 17 points a
game it makes me think more about
investing or the Browns defense later in
the year yeah I just think that the
Raiders are so desperate and I think
when you're playing a team like the
Browns who still are a moniker of losing
it's only gonna motivate you more like
screw these guys but I'm glad we're
spread I'm glad that you have your money
with the Cleveland Browns yeah I only
put ten dollars of it
alright guys next week my team doesn't
win and a tie the New Orleans Saints
coming up to New York two schemes weird
- coming up to New York to visit the
Giants Saints coming off the win over
the Falcons last week Giants got their
first win against the Texans left go
we're gonna start with you this game
Giants Olivia Vernon
limited practice on Wednesday it's the
first time he's even practiced in a
month so that's pretty good little note
here the Giants they are tied for 31st
in the NFL with for sex you need to get
pressure on Drew Brees New Orleans
Patrick Robinson's on the IR really bad
for a team that already had issues in
their secondary plays way too much man a
man and oh yeah here comes Hodel Beckham
jr. everyone saying Odell starting slow
I'm not seeing it
still got like double-digit catches in
two games this year they're gonna figure
it out I mean if this quarterback threw
him the ball in the first game a few
times he's gonna break records and I
know that that one betting favorite is
bet against Drew Brees outside on the
road yeah
I'm not doing that I'd like a hundred
dollars on the Saints in their last 20
mm hey folks in the last 20 home
underdog games the Giants are four and
sixteen the Giants have a problem at
September at home Levin in the last 11
games at home in September they're four
and seven they're two and nine against
the spread they just start slow yeah
following a win since 2016 the Saints
are 13 six and one against the spread
the number one team in the a NFC Shaun
Pete Peyton builds you know Shaun yeah
when they get a win they go let's get
another one let's get another one I
think that their offense I I think it is
starting to click I think that Shawn is
gonna look at this Giants defense and
it's gonna be Kimura on Ogletree and I
think Google trees gonna not have a step
I just trust the Saints more and all the
trends of home and all that stuff leave
me to take New Orleans yeah it's I I
mean I this is this is gonna be a good
football game it's gonna be a great
football game I think it's close I
almost went big on this game like big
you're going Giants I am going Giants
I'm going Giants for $100 Josh knows I
almost before anything
let's go Giants I love it McGee
shove that saxophone up here you know
what New Orleans I love that that
actually got me really your child I felt
like I was sitting in section 236 right
there in the mezzanine level listening
to some people ago your father sucks but
those were the goodness I want to put
whispers in the back well why won't he
throw the [ __ ] football why is you
sit in the pocket all day because every
receiver he has ran for nine okay
Giants Giants okay the first thing is
the Saints defense sucks I mean it sucks
what else is there to say it's letting
up 34 points a game question yeah is it
fair to say that last year was an
aberration if Dennis Allen and the
Saints defense sucked for three years
before last year right and last year
they were great this is a little bit
like Carson Palmer yeah Carson Palmer
was pretty average for three years had
the one good Arizona year and we got
clouded yeah is it possible to say that
last year a beret [ __ ] could be last
year I felt like they kept it very
simple and they were over aggressive
early in the year and they cordon was
incredible right and they finally
started to go you know we don't have to
take all these chances right now they're
being every bit as aggressive still
which I don't understand the d-line is
not as good that's the other thing too
there it's okay if you have to go do you
want to say something there god the only
thing I was gonna say is are they
possibly doing what you want the Chiefs
to do they know that their defense could
be running to the ground so instead
let's attack and get the ball back to
Drew Brees because we know we can out
score you they they could be there they
are gonna take the aggressive approach
which fits their personnel definitely
does you're right you don't want Drew
Brees sitting over there all day and I
totally understand that I think it's
gone a little overboard with the
aggressiveness right and okay if you're
gonna play that much man-to-man this is
the other reason they're not as good on
defense this year Marcia and Lattimore
is not as good I don't know other way to
say it last year top five he's a bright
like this year I would not put him in
the top five
last year Kenny Crawley was something to
like at least be reckoned with I mean
right now he's burnt Ezekiel toast okay
and PJ Williams is the same the same way
they have issues there and I don't think
their defensive line can ruin the game
enough on this Giants offensive line to
where I'll feel good about the back end
Odell and sterling Shepard against these
two guys covering and then also having
to worry about say Quan in the run game
like you're gonna have to pay attention
that you talked about the Giants only
having four sacks this it's only got six
on the year that was why i enhance o
much time right it's it's it's really a
thing this year now flipping it around
to the other side hey I think the Saints
are gonna move the ball to and and I
hear you there I that giant D line still
I think the one thing they got for him
is they're big as hell and I would have
a hard time thinking they're gonna just
run the ball on them to end to wear what
battering is I feel like their runs with
Kimora dumped off some screens they are
I mean they're fine they're gonna find
their ways but I do think because they
can trust their big guys up front that
better can be a little creative on the
backend and they can play enough man to
man from time to time to keep you honest
what's the Eli Apple status what is it
I'm sorry question want to make sure I
think so I think it was I just want to
make sure yeah but either way it is I
pick I'm picking the Giants to win this
game I can't bore 34-28 oh damn yeah I
think it's gonna be somewhat of a
shootout I really do and I think the
Giants are just gonna be able to put
more points on the board in the Saints
Apple practiced on Thursday today good
sign for his weak force - ok alright
this is unrelated to football but I'm
very curious as to Sims reaction to it
after 45 years and more than 1,000
fights
it looks like the Daniel Jacobs fight
will be the last fight on HBO Wow they
are giving up covering boxing and on HBO
they apparently came out during a
production meeting today HBO is getting
out of boxing I only bring this up cuz I
know you're a huge box I am and I love
Jim Lampley and Max Kellerman on HBO
boxing I mean I guess showtimes gonna
take over everything I guess so I was a
big fan of boxing after dark on ESPN and
those were those are my jams I just I
worry about that sport Denton tintin
didn't didn't didn't know that's
Showtime inside last game of the
afternoon
Slade here San Francisco headed down to
LA to visit the Chargers spread in this
game Chargers - 9 and a half left go
we're gonna go to you first here
injuries Keenan Allen didn't practice on
Wednesday again we're doing this on
Thursday so that could be a deal there
Joey Bosa now saying he might be out
until at least week 8 yeah if you were
to stack up the people that I dislike
the most in the world
I'd say the Chargers medical staff is
near the top stop ruining great team be
a fun segment who does let go dislike
most in the world I might have it for
Monday I would say the number one person
is the comment the guy that comments
under my girlfriend's pictures with your
boyfriend sucks at picking game that's
great I don't know if that actually
exists I'm just guessing that he's out
there 9 1 talk about injuries holy crap
Jimmy G out for the year Richard Sherman
not playing starting safeties Kolbert
and tart both questionable by the way
Wednesday Josh Garnett and Mike person
boast met both missed practice right I'm
Slade was breda questionable I know cuz
his that was nasty I can't believe he
actually was okay I thought he tore his
ACL I am putting $100 on San Francisco
I don't even know this song this is what
they were trying to imitate the barely
five Niners where's he Sayer we're
dynamite dynamite dynamite was a word
used a lot in the 80s and didn't make it
into the 90s and 2000's dynamite
dynamite was to use described a lot of
stuff and then probably some QC person
came along and said we don't want to
talk about explosion Shanahan's nickname
and halo was Shanno might so you're
telling me that when you played halo
with Kyle Shanahan at Texas right his
user tag was shadow my shadow might
instead of dynamite of a shadow my chat
what was your user sensation
you've been killed by sensation your
television station in the same Halo game
those are the good old days shadow might
who was better at halo me man why was
the man what was his favorite weapon uh
gosh it depends on let me guess he was
really strategic weight he was way too
strategic always he tried to play Madden
like it was real like oh I brand that
ball to the three technique that should
work every time we were like dude it's a
video game stop like what are you
drawing at your first 15 over here like
some dork coach you know so he would get
really upset even really get into it yes
yes so that was always fun whooping his
butt in that amazing all right I haven't
gone yet
oh so I'm going a hundred dollars on the
Niners here's why I'm wrong last five
years when the Chargers are favorites of
nine or more points it's happened five
times they're five and oh yeah however
there are two and three against the
spread the reason I'm going with the
Niners is they're use to this and
they're really good at this right
they were underdogs of nine or more
without Jimmy last year four times they
went oh and four yeah but like they went
the three they went three and one
against the spread right the Niners were
covering a lot of games last year during
that losing streak with CJ Beathard
here's the other thing
there has been no quarterback that is
thrown to the running backs more in the
last decade than CJ Beathard the
strength of the Niners team will be
better it will be Juicy J my issue with
the Chargers is they get sloppy and if
there's one team that's gonna make them
look really really sloppy
it's the Niners I expect a lot of oh Sh
it's a lot of of's
when the Niners are on offense and I
think nine and a half honestly I just
don't trust the Chargers right now
nothing about them they have no
home-field advantage I have one fear my
only fear for the Niners other than the
fact that I'm a starting quarterback and
all that is what's happening on Friday
Carter five is released I need Kyle
Shanahan to come in with a big game plan
and my fear is that he's gonna be
listening to the new Lil Wayne album on
repeat I think that you should wipe that
fear away cuz they don't only make him
better he's the kind of guy that could
like literally put on the headphones and
feel it and then drop a new offense so
you're telling me that this weekend
Friday and Saturday
Kyle Shanahan will be in his office
bumping the new Lil Wayne Carter five is
sitting there going I have the plan I'm
beautiful mind chalkboards everywhere
Lil Wayne bumping my Chargers are
screwed I'm flipping it Niners are
winning outright upsetting with CJ
Beathard Lil Wayne Carter five Niners
win by five
are you really flipping that well I mean
I already picked the Niners okay you're
picking there's the win the game out
right now I am by five in honor of the
Carter five Sims your breakdown on this
game okay I'm betting $100 on the Los
Angeles chargers talk about a letdown
bed
and Diego you can't dance with a pick
fork waiting go look right 49ers use
pitchforks like a pickaxe better song
the Niners song or that song the
supercharger song was at the same point
it doesn't really they're not the San
Diego supercharged now I know they're
gonna la baie EB loser charge Jason I
like the chart alright seems your
breakdown okay I think the big thing is
here III
38:28 victory for the Chargers I picked
the score before they saw this spread so
I'm sticking with what that is it's nine
and a half spread okay the big thing is
I do think the 49ers can keep this close
because the Chargers run defense is
atrocious and I think with a week like
CJ Beathard starting a quarterback that
Kyle will be even extra more conscious
on the run game controlling the clock a
little bit and trying to keep the
Chargers offense off the field that way
you mentioned some of the injuries I am
worried about Breda if he doesn't play
that's a concern for me he's the most
explosive player on their offense until
Marcus Goodwin gets back totally healthy
that bothers me too you talked about the
defense issues and the defensive issues
for a team that's letting up 287 yards a
game passing against Phillip Rivers in
this group damn that's where I just
don't trust it so I could see it being
closed for a while certainly and then
hanging in there both of these teams let
up way too many points but I'm just
gonna go in the fact that I think this
would be a shootout yeah CJ Beathard
slips up at some point when the game's
3128 and then Phillip goes down and
scores to make it 38 28 and the charger
that is honestly my least confident pick
of the week is the pick I'm expecting to
lose I'm just going against the grain
because the Chargers have let me down
literally every week to here a 49ers
have let me down every week but the
49ers have also been in every game I'm
just hoping I mean CJ Beathard is so I'm
really hoping he gets hurt and then Matt
Sims comes in sorry CJ love you I didn't
mean to put that out there but I'm
really rooting for Matt how's he gonna
get signs I don't know yeah all right
guys moving on Sunday Night Football the
Baltimore Ravens coming off a win last
week against the bronc
on the road visiting the Pittsburgh
Steelers Steelers a three-point favorite
in this game Sims we'll start with you
okay I am going to put $40 and then this
hurt me this one I know I'm gonna pick
the Ravens to win this football game
do it send the dogs
the Ravens coming send them down into
the steel halls of digging hurt they
don't dig for steel do they send the
Ravens to remind you of the world cause
you will fall victim to your dying all
right
the Ravens defense is very good it is
the Ravens offense is as good as it's
been in a while yep I mean they can run
the ball and they can scare you with the
pass game for since maybe the first time
of the year they won the Superbowl back
in 2012 so those are two things I look
at and just go wow okay the Steelers
offense they can run the football but
I'm not gonna sit here and go oh let's
hang our hat on there run game and I
would think that they're gonna have a
hard time running the football on the
Baltimore Ravens I just think the
Baltimore Ravens I have less questions
about them as a team right now
I think they're on a mission too and I
think with the Ravens in the state of
their defense I think this is a tough
matchup for them I have a hard time
thinking that some of their blitz and
creative things will hit home against
this good offensive line with the Ravens
that's usually technically sound that
picking this stuff up as well and I
think Flacco is playing pretty damn good
football with some guys that can they
can go down the foot the field and get
it I'm going to take the Ravens to win
the game outright 27 24 so yeah I guess
I have him it was a three-point spread
right it was yes so you're taking the
Ravens why did that hurt you I cuz the
Steelers are like my Super Bowl team and
I root for the Steelers because I do
like Mike Tomlin and and I like you know
a lot of the guys on their football team
but I can't do it he left got
injury-wise Pittsburgh it's
kind of positive they're hoping to get
to Castro and Marcus Gilbert back this
gig which I mean that offensive line has
been together for a long time if they
have Baltimore opposite Ronnie Stanley
missed Wednesday with a foot injury and
he already has an elbow injury Ronnie
Stanley top ten pick
he is always beset by injuries one of
the knocks against him if he doesn't
play James Hurst moves to left tackle
and Orlando Brown jr. would get his
first start at right tackle I got no
issue with that I know you dad I think I
think this is either going to be his
breakout game where you look like a
genius and everyone else is stupid or
they're facing the Steelers who have 11
sacks already yeah and he's confused at
the twist the girls and all that stuff
I'd probably lean more that way yeah I
am going to be putting down $100 Josh on
the Pittsburgh Steelers you got it left
go Steelers have beaten the Ravens three
in a row more importantly the game is on
prime-time yep the Steelers have won 10
in a row on prime time including Tampa
Bay this goes back three years Mike
Tomlin emotional guy he gets them up for
the big games they play down to the
other teams they are seven and three
against the spread in that 10 game
winning streak last time at the Ravens
had to go to Pittsburgh that really good
defense yeah they allowed 39 points in a
3938 shootouts it is in Pittsburgh what
did I say on Wednesdays podcaster may
have been Monday
I think the Ravens are gonna go eight
and Oh at home I think that they're
gonna go four and four on the road I had
them at 12 and 4 that's how I think they
finish the year they looked amazing
hosting Buffalo they looked amazing
hosting the Broncos they looked slow and
Flacco looked bad in Cincinnati yes I
think that happens this week in
Pittsburgh it's a prime-time game
they're gonna get up I think the
Steelers still feel desperate and I
think they go and they win that game by
like
four is a tough one yeah it's really all
I know is super excited to watch it on
Sunday Night Football - I like good
games that will be a great game will be
they will be killing each other I just
think I want to say it's really quick
Ben Roethlisberger has been phenomenal
all year long except for the bat Browns
game which is extinct was all his fault
right
I would argue that the Ravens offense
has looked good it's all Javari isalud
in the flat and lob balls to John Brown
yeah John Brown has been a revelation
for the Ravens let's see the Steelers
have a lot more athletes and I'm curious
when those balls come I am - who's gonna
come down that was really the reason I
just I just don't quite trust it the
backend I have hoped for that defense
like I told you in Monday just don't
trust it that's why I went with the
Ravens all right guys last game of the
week to pick here before we get to a
little GTL and left go shitbird so we're
gonna go Monday night football here
Kansas City Chiefs on the road visiting
the Denver Broncos Chiefs are a four and
a half point favorite in this game in
Denver I know laughs go we'll start with
you
Brandon Marshall missed Wednesday's
practice for Denver he was really the
only guy that was hurt
Kansas City d4 disc uestion Abul so yeah
I'm back her that's unbelievable I
didn't know that he's questionable
doesn't mean he's out okay um I am going
to be going with the Chiefs at $100
number one reason I don't want to bet
against the Chiefs anymore
here's why I'm wrong as a home underdog
in the last three years the Broncos are
6 and 2 against the spread unfortunately
for the Broncos I have a million reasons
why the Chiefs are the right pick here
Broncos are 1 in 3 straight up in their
last four prime time games the Chiefs
have beaten the Broncos five in a row
the Chiefs in primetime in their last
nine prime time games eight and one
straight up eight and one against the
spread and yareta on prime time he's
ready to go but here is the divisional
thing I said this about the Seahawks it
is the same thing with Andy Reed the
Chiefs shocker Pete Carroll and the
Seahawks have are good against their
opponents Andy Reid and the Chiefs are
good against their opponents they know
how to beat the teams they're used to in
last 18 games against the AFC West the
Chiefs are seven teen and one let that
sink that's amazing Raiders they've had
their moments yeah
Broncos they freakin won the Super Bowl
a few years ago hey um Who am I missing
the Chargers Chargers they've been
always there seventeen and one not only
that against the spread in their last 31
games against the AFC West 21 and 10 the
best against the spread record against
their division in the last five years
the Chiefs on prime-time against an AFC
West opponents had dere near being a
lock I expect case qiyam in the offense
to click I expect them to put up points
heck I expect them to even have a big
lead at a halftime and Patrick mahomes
to screw up but when it starts clicking
it's gonna be an avalanche
I think the Chiefs win and I think they
win by a touchdown
I'm putting $100 on the Chiefs already
you Sims okay how did you feel after
hearing all no I I mean I I have a
similar view to you I'm going a hundred
dollars on the Broncos but I'm picking
the Chiefs to win the game I figured the
Chiefs to win
31 I just didn't see the 35 30 35 31 I
mean that the the Broncos can move the
football too and the Chiefs defense is
still not good I still have too many
questions
I really do but the other thing that
scares me you know on the flip side
there is the Broncos have the people
have been throwing the ball on the
Broncos in every game and damn this is
the greatest show on turf right now
Derek Carr had a near-perfect
performance right Russell Wilson was
able to find Brandon Marshall and Tyler
Lockett deep but there are other players
and then last week Baltimore like Flacco
had a pretty good job Brown was out yeah
so that's that's that's what I worry
about in this football game
I do think this will be a back and forth
football game I think one thing that
goes and we talked about a little
yesterday I think the cheap serve their
defense is very good on third down in
fact it's the only thing they're good at
at all and that's because they will do
some unconventional things where you
just go dim I really don't know what
they're doing here it's hard to prepare
it's hard to tell my line to block these
guys it's hard to tell this receiver I
think they're playing this coverage and
where I just think they have a little
bit of an edge out of the fact that this
is the most explosive offense in the
sport it's very hard to play in Denver
but I don't think the Denver pass rush
is going to be able to disrupt this game
enough for me to sit here and go the
Chiefs won't move the ball up and down
the field on them that's why I go Chiefs
35:31 but at a four and a half points
was just a little hair too much for me
and I think the Denver covers I just
wanted to look this up really quick
Denver in terms of rushing attempts per
game is in the top ten and I think
that's I'm waiting to see which team is
gonna really control the clock and pound
it out against the Chiefs yeah and I
don't know if it's the Phillip Lindsey
Royce Freeman
Devante Booker show because if not I'm
taking Pat mahomes and Andy Reed over
Case Keenum and Vance game coin toss is
huge what do you mean hold on this is
something to look for in the city if
Kansas City gets the ball and goes that
they change the dynamic of the game
right away when you go down oh damn
we're down seven nothing and then the
first drive you start to go where we
were gonna run the ball and do that but
damn I might you know that's third play
I might go with a pass play instead now
because I just am a little scared or
whatever it may be they put so much
pressure on you and that in that way
that's where it becomes scary alright
guys that's all the games so here's
we're gonna do I'll give the rundown of
the disagreements here left go if you
want to be picking your lock Sims if you
want to be doing your GTL disagreements
from this week you guys disagreed on
Thursday Night Football Sims you went
Minnesota plus seven left go went with
the Rams minus seven Miami no
disagreement here you guys both pick the
Dolphins plus nine and a half seems you
actually pick the Dolphins to win the
game and put $400 on it how you feeling
about that pick I feel good about that
alright Philadelphia Tennessee Sims you
went I feel good that they're gonna
cover for sure I don't know if I feel
great that they're gonna win the okay
Philadelphia so Sims you went with the
Eagles minus three left go you went with
Tennessee plus three moving on down here
a lot of agreements in the middle of the
show Cleveland Oakland Cleveland okay
Cleveland Oakland Sims you went with the
Browns left go you went with the Raiders
Giants Saints Sims went with the Giants
plus three left goin't with the Saints
minus three left go you had the 49er
plus nine and a half Sims went with the
Chargers in that game Sunday Night
Football Sims goes with Baltimore left
go you go with the Steelers and then
Monday Night Football Sims goes with the
Broncos plus four and a half left go you
took the Chiefs - four and a half
alright so I have five teams that I'm
contemplating making left ko locks I am
NOT making Miami a left Kolok I'm just
too afraid of of I pick against them but
I feel really dumb that New England just
blew them out one I feel certain about
Seattle at Arizona plus three or minus
three right I feel like I want to get my
money in there against Arizona again I
think they had their show out and all
that stuff I really like the other ones
I'm thinking about our indie as a
pick'em against Houston I'm thinking
about Detroit plus three and a half in
Dallas I'm thinking about Chicago - one
and a half against Tampa Bay and I'm
thinking about Cincinnati plus five and
a half oh I stopped listening to you
last week because your own eight so I
don't know I'm asking for your [ __ ]
don't you want my help yeah I don't
think you should want no no no kiss here
here's what I'm thinking is even though
I lost Chicago to Arizona last week you
felt I was on the right side I know it
sucks about betting so here's my thing
Indy Houston pick'em I feel pretty good
about Indy I'm worried about a few shots
deep and I'm worried about this injury
report that I don't know what it's gonna
be yet okay Detroit getting three and a
half in Dallas of course I'm worried
about the Zeke run but I also know that
if I have Matt Stafford on my side I
feel like I'm gonna feel pretty good in
that game right in terms of Chicago
hosting Tampa Bay I feel pretty good
about that Chicago defense and Vic
Fangio I'm actually gonna lock that in
right now I actually like Chicago at
home right there the other one is
Cincinnati plus five and a half that one
I don't know about so is it Indian
Detroit am I taking luck versus - do you
have more faith in Cincinnati getting
five and a half I do yes I do it's a lot
of points and now too much and like you
said that I mean it's
it's an equal it's an equal game there I
mean it's I would argue maybe
Cincinnati's slightly the more talent I
don't know about so then Indy as a
pick'em against Houston or Detroit
India's origin or Detroit getting three
and a half in Dallas at least with India
I'm getting a home team I think I would
rather go Indy there because here
because so then if I do Indy and Chicago
that's two home teams Cincinnati in
Seattle two road teams if I go to Troy I
could totally see Zeke running for like
a hundred and sixty yards that way I'm
betting against Houston I'm betting
against the Bucks after a Monday night
game I'm betting against Emily in
Arizona right that's it your left
comments are gonna be the cult it's now
time he can't figure it out the
guarantees thrown out the window the
warranties don't come and claim them but
let's fix it up right here Sims the mush
and the Sims
together again Garin teeth to lose so
far we're the only two that have been
losing in these two segments guarantee
we are guaranteed but it's gonna change
this week I'm about to go on fire eat it
everybody okay we're starting out on
Thursday night the Minnesota Vikings
welcome to guaranteed to lose you're
gonna lose you're not as good as the
Rams and your coach has been making
excuses up for four days sorry that's a
big al in Los Angeles where we had an
exchange
we're going down to Jackson Bills Bills
doesn't have a song like that it's a
rookie quarterback against the best
defense in football and I like the just
to keep it close but gosh damn and they
ain't gonna beat the Jaguars down in
Jacksonville see you next time Jeff
seems you know what you don't want to
face the greatest quarterback of all
time after he just lost quarterback
making his second start ever up in Green
Bay a little scary oh and I do think
Aaron Rodgers will be on fire in this
football game
Buffalo might hang around for a little
bit while but the bottom at the end of
the day it is Rodgers greater than Allen
and Allen has no help around him still
even with little sean mccoy getting
somewhat healthy next we're going to a
rookie quarterback that looks really
weird in the helmet he does I don't know
about all of that but Josh Rosen I do
think will be a step up at the
quarterback position but man the
Cardinals stink defensive run defense
has horrible defensive run defense as a
technical term and I just have no faith
in the Arizona Cardinals offense in
general I think Rosen's a step up but
they're going to lose to Russell Wilson
in the Seattle Seahawks and last they
used to be best friends but now they're
frenemies he continues to pick against
his buddy
do it again and he keeps delivering
right now it's hard for me not to pick
against them by his quarterback is CJ
Beathard this week and he's going
against Phillip Rivers
the 49ers past defense is not good and
the Chargers light up the air with their
pass game on a weekly basis I'm going to
go five and out and there it is the
Vikings the Jets the bills the Cardinals
of the Niners you've been guaranteed
possibly to win because Sims is
guaranteeing you to lose don't forget to
have your pet spayed and neutered
Plinko was brought to you by Hasbro
Hasbro the makers of the frisbee
Thursday Night Football guaranteed to
lose people listen to this Friday
morning that is that's dangerous to deal
with it all right I think that's the end
of the podcast thank God
there it is I had a lot of fun this time
I just felt like the most clean did feel
clean I definitely felt the most
prepared I started a few times alright
so again Saturday when Samms is doing
Notre Dame stuff if you want to take a
picture of him while he's on television
and we make a meme out of it let's do it
Sunday hop on the socials check out Sims
and Lefko we post pictures on IG during
the game I usually do a story of my
setup here at the office if you want to
talk to me I'll be here this Sunday whoa
and then also we will be on the Twitter
so be sure to interact with us and again
the hashtag for Sunday is embrace the
mush I've already told you my left cole
ox they're gonna be I can't believe I'm
doing this
the Colts in a 50-50 pick how many times
are we gonna come over this the Bears
the Bengals and the Seahawks music Nick
if you're betting against me
use the hashtag in brain
the mus you do not understand social
media do not understand the probably
somewhere in 30 minutes and that last
one minutes gonna make him late for Sims
peace out homies for Fenric good evening
and for the lef koe man he still does it
talk to you later
he thought he hates me yeah I gotta go
like seriously